a ideia só vale a pena quando são
compartilhadas é verdade você vai me
ajudar uma pequena experiência tá bom eu
não faço eu sumir por favor fica
tranquilo eu vou sumir com o seu
microfone de suas mãos as suas mãos não
precisa ficar com medo era todo mundo
consegue ver as notas de falar em si e
sim pra baixo
isso é uma coisa que bom que você
escreve direito a baixar
canela um xis aqui na minha mão
um x de ter conseguem vender não
conseguem ver e isso nossa intenção é
ser x ele pode representar várias coisas
o conhecimento aprendizado uma idéia uma
idéia que merece ser compartilhada
abra mão abre mão
este site não sabe quando a gente
aprende alguma coisa isso marcão gente
não vai mais sair falando disse
anteriores
obrigado a revolução profunda sobre com
ele
agora todos vocês façam assim com as
mãos
assim fechem as mãos abre as mãos dentro
da mão de vocês têm um pequeno chip
brincando folgando mas vocês vão sair
daqui hoje todos vocês sem sombra de
dúvida todos vão sair marcados por
várias novas idéias
eu quero compartilhar uma ideia com
vocês eu trouxe um baralho é um baralho
normal
vou dar a ele de presente para alguém ea
idéia é essa
vamos pensar que esse barak representa
uma sociedade uma sociedade com várias
cartas tá cá várias idéias vamos falar
assim de cada idéia está num canto estão
bem distintas de uma pessoa você com
você você mesmo é você não pode cair eu
vou passar às quartas assim você fala
pro pará onde você quiser
antes de terminar a olhar para o eleitor
eu quero que você seja essa carta é a
sua idéia lembra a mãe dela a idéia é se
vocês olharem o lateral desse de cartas
têm alguns símbolos aqui eles não fazem
muito sentido mas se eu pegar essas
idéias não terá salas assim unindo as
idéias você vai ver que elas vão
começando começando a fazer sentido
talvez o episódio não tá vendo direito
então vamos ganhar de novo se entrelaça
suas idéias
elas começam a dialogar mas começam a
conversar entre si e vão ganhando cada
vez mais sentido
se vocês olharem bem de perto além do
telão assim ó entrelaçando as idéias ela
se ao diálogo mas também identificada
idéia estava no canto tarde deta um
tanto
agora elas se unem e se vocês forem ver
as cartas estão as 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 valente dama rei todas
as cartas ficam em ordem mas você tinha
uma idéia a primeira vez com essa idéia
qualquer a carta 5 decoração é o cinco
de copas
olhem bem devagar
olha lá
presente pra você pode pegar
por exemplo o conhecimento só tem
sentido quando ele é compartilhada
se falta cartas no baralho as coisas não
funcionam as idéias ela soma elas se
entrelaçam ela se espalha e por isso que
hoje é um dia mágico um dia de
compartilhar idéias muito obrigado
[Aplausos]